hospitals and medical clinics have
repeatedly come under attack in Syria
scenes like these caused outrage around
the world in many cases doctors had
given the coordinates to the United
Nations
so the clinics wouldn't be bombed but
despite this they were deliberately
targeted under considerable pressure
last summer the UN secretary-general
Antonio Guterres set up a board of
inquiry to look into seven incidents
it's now produced its report saying it
was highly probable that the Assad
regime and its allies were responsible
for three attacks plausible they were
behind another attack and highly
probable the Syrian government alone
carried out of fifth bombing the inquiry
team say their findings are not
conclusive because the Syrian government
gave them no assistance and refused to
give them visas to enter the country it
would have been a much better and much
thorough process if all member states
had cooperated fully with the inquiry
the United Nations operates in Syria on
behalf of all Member States we were
there the board of inquiry was to look
at the damage done and a number of
facilities funded bombing a hospital is
a war crime but don't expect any
accountability for what's detailed here
in the past when the Security Council
has tried to refer events in Syria to
the International Criminal Court it's
been blocked by Russia a permanent
member using its veto and I'm told
even Security Council members who are
normally critical of Moscow do not want
to have a meeting of the Security
Council right now that's because on the
ground enid Lib there's an uneasy calm
and they don't want to provoke the
Russians right now James BAE's al
Jazeera at the United Nations